je suis en france la première mineur qui
a refusé le 8 loi des violeurs qui
voulait que tout le monde puisse venir
c'est pas moi d'avoir honte je pars pour
quelques heures d'enfer où je fais
violer par ces deux hommes après une
semaine dans un appartement là où il
habite d'ailleurs dans leur cité ce que
je sais c'est de les faillis vraiment
mourir ce jour là j'ai failli prendre
une balle ça c'est clair
voilà j'ai vu un seul pistolet de ma vie
c'est cette nuit là un moment les deux
hommes partent jaurès dans l'appartement
du troisième homme il occupait mais
j'entends d'autres voies et quand je
sors de la chambre habile il est prêt à
partir
je tombe sur deux jeunes que je ne
connaissais pas qui pose deux questions
très vite je comprend très vite qu'ils
ont eu un différend le matin même ou la
veille et que et voilà est ce qu'une
balance leur nom grâce à ces deux hommes
j'ai pu voir le long de mes violeurs les
deux personnes affligées va faire ce
sont deux voyous notoires qui était déjà
là en prison
l'un des cousins de l'autre le cousin
est sorti la veille
[Musique]
j'arrivais dans un état j'étais brûlé
sur le visage
on m'avait pisser dessus il pleuvait pas
enfin voila je dégoulinait d'un truc je
déconnais de la viole un truc glauque
quoi donc enfin je veux dire ça se
voyait
cette voyelle je venais juste de vivre
l'enfer on c'est vachement bien occupé
de moi donc oui j'ai de la chance parce
que j'ai pas subi un choc de plus j'ai
pas subi un autre choc dans un
commissariat on me parlait mal dans un
hôpital ou dans un service gynéco on
aurait maltraité en deux mots je n'ai
pas subi ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand il prononce le mot huis clos mais
c'est un mot que je connais pas et donc
je lance ce que ça signifie donc il
m'explique à huis clos comme vous étiez
mineure au moment des faits personne ne
pourra rentrer dans la salle il y aura
le président cour d'assises les jurés
voilà toutes les personnes et puis c'est
tout j'ai et josiane et non à lendemain
j'ai dit moi je veux qu'on ouvre les
portes et donc à ce moment-là je
refusais le huis clos
il a été ce coaching quelqu'un très pro
via une grande maîtrise qui m'a regardé
très calmement qui m'a dit pourquoi
pourquoi vous refusez et là je répondu
mais c'est parce que c'est pas moi
d'avoir honte pour mme en fait été d'une
évidence c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais
eu honte
enfin je les ai jamais ressenti
culpabilité de honte parce que c'est
juste pas moi d'avoir honte en fait trop
mais ton de choses à l'endroit
la honte c'est pas pour les victimes
donc à partir de là les portes ne devait
pas te faire mais moi j'ai je lui ai dit
moi je veux que tout le monde le sache
je veux tout le monde puisse venir je
veux que la société sache alors ce qui
est paradoxal c'est que j'en parle pas
mes parents alors paradoxe elle oui ou
non parce qu'on peut avoir des raisons
pour faire quelque chose
eh bien faisons pour ne pas les faire
puisque j'avais décidé de porter plainte
et de me débrouiller seul
j'allais me débrouiller seul ça voulait
dire et le juge jean pierre getti l'a
compris je lui dis il m'a dit il m'a
exposé un une difficulté réelle c'est
que étant mineurs au moment des faits me
par an de vins venus signer pour moi si
je refusais le huis clos
or et c'est là où s'est retrouvé le face
à quelque chose
j'imagine de peu habituelle or je ne
voulais pas qu'il soit au courant
donc je vais demander de trouver une
solution mon grand frère l'aîné est
venue est venu signer donc il m'a ali
il est accompagné d'un jour au palais de
justice il n' y signer les documents et
les repartiez je vais dit merci voilà
moi je voulais pas les impliquer
davantage
je voulais pas leur en parler j'avais
dit à mes frais ramasseurs voilà qui
m'est arrivé voilà les démarches que je
j'entreprends et on n'en parle pas aux
parents je gère ça et j'ai géré ça
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
moi ce que je voulais en portant plainte
était déjà que justice soit faite et les
empêcher de recommencer auprès d'autres
personnes parce que des violeurs ça ne
s'arrête pas c'est à dire il ya une fois
mis en a d'autres et je voulais être la
dernière à qu'il faisait du mal
le plus important c'est on a failli
mourir clairement on est morte en partie
je parle quand je dis morte je ne parle
pas que des femmes
je parle de toute personne les enfants
les hommes qui ont vécu à toute personne
calcul ça c'est une atteinte à sa vie
donc après il faut se reconstruire et ça
prend du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je demande à ce que le viol soit reconnu
comme crime contre l'humanité
c'est pour moi après renseignement la
seule façon de lever du délai de
prescription et ça permettrait de faire
la lumière sur plan d'affaires et ça
permettrait aussi qu'il y est c'est ce
que je dis un moment dans mon livre
qu'il y ait une espèce d'épée de
damoclès sur la tête des personnes parce
que quel nom prend perpète quand même
nous on prend perpète
moi je fais encore des cauchemars de
viol évidemment et dans la journée mme
barry d'y penser
alors j'ai des techniques pour refouler
ses idées il pense à autre chose et puis
je gère ni fils différemment j'ai
bientôt 54 ans voilà ça fait plus de
trente six ans et demi
joseph ce jeu jav ça différemment mais
nous on prend perpète ces personnes
devraient avant même qu'elles passent à
l'acte avoir une sorte d'épée de
damoclès
qu'elle sache clairement ce qu'elle en
cours